I'm not sure what direction they're
gonna head but I think that what we're
going to see is that there's has been
really a very large influence of Thomas
crenn's on the museum world in general I
know that doesn't answer your question
because by the time this comes out
frankly they could have hired someone
and it won't really make any sense but
I'll say that there were things that for
example branding when he came in from
the Yale School of organization and
management and he was talking about
branding and everyone said off this is
completely inappropriate for the world
of fine arts museums now they all talk
about branding for example the start the
the legacy of this idea of the
starchitect is a little mixed and in
fact after the success of the Bilbao
Guggenheim there were plans for all
kinds of other Guggenheim's in Austria
and Rio and Mexico in Taiwan all of the
metastasis architects and none of them
happened
because all of these projects again are
combinations of finance diplomacy
politics local governments they're very
hard to get off the ground and in the
end a place like Bilbao where there's a
provincial government which really had a
lot of money that was a very special
case in someplace like Rio where there's
not that kind of money because the
standard of living in Brazil is very
different than the standard of living in
northern Spain it's much harder to get
something like that off the ground